This episode is brought to you by Lloyd's business and commercial banking. One of the great things about finance is that it may result in you having to pay tax. And this was a constant grumble in Anglo-Saxon England, which was the most heavily taxed country in the whole of Christendom. And just when the Anglo-Saxons thought it couldn't get any worse, they got conquered by King Canute. And Canute imposed a tax rate that was effectively... 100%. Yeah, well, that was one very big change, Tom, but another tax change is upon us. And this is the advent of making tax digital for income tax. And if you're at all concerned about it, this is where Lloyd's come in, because they're here to help make that change much
simpler for you with a useful HMRC-recognised accounting tool that will help you stay in line with all the making tax digital requirements. And the brilliant thing about this is, is that it is free for Lloyd's business account customers. So when it is time to digitize your income tax, you can bank on Lloyd's. Search Lloyd's business accounts to find out more. In Toronto, every arrival is a statement, and nothing says it better than this.
Cadillac Optic was the number one selling luxury EV in Canada for 2025. Find your rhythm across a seamless 33-inch display and an immersive 19-speaker AKG surround audio system. This city demands agility and optic delivers with precision to make every drive extraordinary. Let's take the Cadillac. Find out more at Cadillac Canada.ca. Luxury sales claim based on S&P Global Mobility Canadian New Vehicle Total Registrations for calendar year 2025 for the Cadillac definition of luxury. At dusk, all lights were put out and the troops rested for the ordeal at dawn.
It was a beautiful calm night with a bright half-moon. As the moon waned, the boats were swung out, the Australians received their last instructions, and men who six months ago were living peaceful civilian lives began to disembark on a strange, unknown shore, in a strange land, to attack an enemy of different race. The boats had almost reached the beach when a party of Turks entrenched ashore
opened a terrible fuselard. The Australians rose to the occasion. They did not wait for orders or for the boats to reach the beach, but sprang into the sea, formed a sort of rough line, and rushed the enemy's trenches. Their magazines were uncharged, so they just went in with cold steel. I have never seen anything like these wounded Australians in war before. Though many were shot to bits, without hope of recovery, their cheers resounded throughout the night. They were happy, because they knew they had been tried for the first time,
and had not been found wanting. There has been no finer feat in this war than this sudden landing in the dark and storming the heights, and above all, holding on while the reinforcements were landing. These raw colonial troops in these desperate hours proved worthy to fight side by side with the heroes of Mons, the Aen, Eppre and Nerv Chappelle. So that was the first report of the Allied landings at Gallipoli in Turkey on the 25th of April 1915, and it was written by a chap called Ellis Ashmead Bartlett, and he was the war correspondent of the Daily Telegraph. And when it was reproduced in the newspapers in Australia a couple of weeks later, it caused an absolute sensation. And his praise for the courage of the Anzac troops, so the Australians and the New Zealanders, became a source of immense national pride down under.
And it was all the sweeter because, as you could tell from my expert reproduction of his accent, Ashmead Bartlett wasn't Australian. You would, of course, expect an Australian commentator to big up Australian performance. But this chap was British. and so to quote one Australian historian and there it was, were they to fight side by side, we belonged and we've been told so by a pom. I don't think it said by a pom.
It says by an Englishman. No, he did it. He said by an Englishman. He did say by an Englishman. So as our Australian listeners will know and our Kiwi listeners as well, this is one of the foundational moments in their national identity.
Perhaps the key moment, I don't know. And it's also, of course, intriguingly and suggestively a key moment in the formation of what will become in due course, the Republic of Turkey. So, Dominic, it is a really historically significant episode. Absolutely it is. For countries that are, you know, as different as Australia and New Zealand and Turkey. But it's also, it's not a story in which Britain comes out well. I mean, it's kind of, let's be blunt, it's a cataclysmic disaster. It is. So, hello everybody. Yes, it's a massively important moments in the history of Australia, New Zealand and indeed Turkey, but it's also one of the most colourful and gripping stories of the entire First World War. And as you say, Gallipoli ranks among the great military catastrophes of modern times. And you say the British don't come out well. I mean, some Britain's come out extremely well, but others do not. And chief among those who do not is arguably the most celebrated man in all British history, Winston Churchill. So let me rephrase.
that, we've been talking about this phrase lions led by donkeys throughout and kind of slightly debunking it, I think this is the example of lions being led by absolute idiots. Well, we shall see. We shall see. I mean, among the men at Gallipoli, not just Winston Churchill, the man who carries the can for this disastrous operation, but Churchill's wartime deputy in the Second World War and successor as Prime Minister, Clement Attlee. He was a captain. And he has a horrible time, doesn't he, kind of crawling around among poo? Yes, dysentery, yes, dysentery. the father of modern Turkey,
the single best known Turkish person of the last couple of hundred years, Mustafa Kemal Ataturk, father Turk. He makes his name at Gallipoli. Australia's greatest military hero, John Monash, he makes his name at Gallipoli. But all roads lead back to the man who came up with the entire scheme.
The wheeze. Yes, the man who dominates 20th century British history And that man is, of course, the then First Lord of the Admiralty, Winston S. Churchill, because it's his idea to turn the tide of the First World War by landing thousands of British, French, Australian and New Zealand troops on the Gallipoli Peninsula, south of Constantinople. And we will see how that works out. So for those who listen to our series on the Battle of Marathon, that's the Thracian-Chersenese, as was. The Hellespont, isn't it? It is exactly the Hellespont. So let's start with Churchill himself.
At the turn of 1915, Winston Churchill is still only 40 years old. And a couple of years ago, we did a series on the young Churchill looking at his life, particularly in the 1890s. He has had an extraordinary life up to this point, an extraordinary four decades. He's fought in India, in Sudan, in South Africa. He was famously captured by the Burrs and escaped from a prisoner of war camp. He became a Tory MP. then he defected to the Liberals.
He became Home Secretary for the Liberals, for the Asquith government, then First Lord of the Admiralty, his dream job really, running the Royal Navy, and he's been there since 1911. And when war approached in the late summer of 1914, Churchill was terribly excited. He loved the idea of a war. He's a martial sort of person. He's always put himself in harm's way, and he can't wait to get stuck in.
and a few months later, even after it's obvious that the war is going to be a terrible classicism for Europe, he's still thrilled and excited by it. So he sits next to Margot Asquith, the Prime Minister's wife at a dinner on the 10th of January and he says to her, my God, this is living history. It will be read by a thousand generations. Think of that. Why I would not be out of this glorious, delicious war for anything the world could give me. And then he stops and he says, I say, don't repeat that I said the word delicious. You know what I mean. I mean, he's a man who loves actually, I mean, not just excitement, but a disaster.
Because he famously said of the Titanic that it was a triumph for British pluck. Exactly. Which I think it's one way of framing it. And this is another one. Yes, it is indeed. This week. Yes. And of course, for Churchill, the great disappointment of the war is that he is the first
lord of the Admiralty, but the German fleet by and large stays in port. So he doesn't get the great naval showdown that he's hoping for. Even so, Churchill seizes every opportunity to put himself at the center of this stage. So only a couple of months into the war in October 1914, he sends what's basically a sort of private army that is cobbled together of naval reservists, the Royal Naval Division, to Antwerp, which is still under siege by the Germans. He says, my Royal Naval Division will save Antwerp, and he actually goes himself to Antwerp, and he offers ask with his resignation and says, I would like to take personal charge.
of the defence of Antwerp. This is refused. Antwerp promptly falls. And everybody back home says Churchill made an absolute fool of himself at Antwerp. He sent the Royal Naval Division for no reason. The press, the morning post, for example, a Tory paper slams him as an erratic amateur. The Secretary of War, Lord Kitchener, says it was a piratical adventure. Even Asquith, the Prime Minister, says it was wicked folly to have sent so many men to Antwerp and to have made such a hullabaloo about it when it was obvious it was going to fall. But the point about Churchill, Churchill loves a gimmick. He loves a wheeze of a stunt.
And he will do anything to put himself at the centre of the story. Do you think, just to stick up for him, because we're going to dump on him quite a lot over the course of this, the next two episodes. I mean, in a sense, he is right, isn't he, that there is this stalemate. And it's obvious on the Western Front, but it is also apparent at sea. And in a sense, if you're going to break the stalemate, perhaps you do need some left field thinking, some blue sky thinking. It's just that his blue sky thinking turns out not to be, well, a bit dark, really. Yeah, it's not, the storm clouds of war are very much present in it in Churchill's blue sky thinking. But there is a problem.
Of course. He's absolutely right that there's a stalemate on the Western Front and that it would be brilliant if they could break it. But his idea, which is we will come up with sort of great distraction and displacement exercises that will somehow, you know, obviate the need for a nutritional campaign on the Western Front. He is deluded. The war is only ever going to be won on the Western Front. I'm amazingly he didn't come up with my wheeze of invading Switzerland. Yes.
We'd have got on, I think. Yeah, you would have got on. Anyway, so he's casting around for something to do. And it's at this point that his gaze falls on the Ottoman Empire. Now, to remind people about the Ottoman Empire, the Ottoman Empire, which is always referred to in the shorthand as Turkey, although it's not just Turkey, of course. The Ottoman dynasty had been ruling in Constantinople for almost 500 years.
And in 1914, they're governing this vast, multi-ethnic, multi-religious empire, multicultural, more than 40 million people from the shores of the Mediterranean to the sands of Arabia. And this empire famously describes as the sick man of Europe is in a pretty ramshackle condition. So having once been one of Europe's great powers, it's now fallen behind the industrial powerhouses of Western Europe. it's still very much a rural agricultural society, pre-industrial in many ways. In the late 19th century, the Ottomans had started to lose their Balkan territories. So they'd lost Serbia. They'd lost Bulgaria.
They'd lost Romania. And in 1908, a group of officers in the army, a little bit like the Meiji Restoration in Japan, a group of army officers who were fed up with this. They were generally European-born, so they were from the Balkans. They were from precisely the part of the empire that was beginning to fragment. and they were called the young Turks, and they decided they wanted to reverse the decline of the empire. They seized power in effectively a coup, and they turned the Sultan into a puppet, and the young Turks now run the empire. And how does that go?
Well, it doesn't go terribly well, because just four years later, the first Balkan war breaks out in 1912, and by the following year, the Ottomans have lost pretty much all their Balkan provinces except for Eastern Thrace, so that's the bit right now. to Constantinople. And some of the possessions they lose are what are now northern Greece, right? Yeah, northern Greece, North Macedonia, parts of sort of Bulgaria, Serbia and so on, Albania. Specifically, they lose the city of Salonica, so Thessaloniki as today, and there is one particular officer who was born there, right? Exactly right.
So, and he is one of many people, hundreds of thousands of people actually, who are driven out of their homes, who lose the homeland, who are murdered, who are killed and so on and so forth. These are Albanian and Turkish Muslims. And this guy in particular, he was born in Solonika, as he would have been called at the time. He's an army officer. He fought against the Bulgarians in Thrace, and his name is Mustafa Kemal. And we'll be coming back to Mustafa Kemal later on. Have you seen this house? I have in Thessaloniki. Yeah, I have. Yes. Next to the Turkish consulate. It's very good. I actually really like Thessaloniki. I think it's great. I mean, a lot of it is very modern because of earthquakes and fires and things. But, yeah, it's a tremendous place. great. Anyway, war breaks out in 1914. And the Ottoman Empire at first, rather like Italy,
doesn't get involved, but it is keen to shop around for the best offer. And the young Turk leadership, in particular their war minister who's called Enver, are basically putting out feelers to various parties saying, what can you offer us? But it's always most likely that they will get into bed with the central powers of Germany and Austria, Hungary. And the reason is that before the First World War, the Germans had worked really hard to win influence in the Ottoman Empire. They'd put loads of money into a very controversial railway link, which was going to go all the way from Berlin to Baghdad. And they had sent a Prussian general, who was called Otto Lehman von Sanders, to modernise the Ottoman Empire along kind of German lines.
Isn't there another reason also why they were always going to side with the central powers, which is that their big paranoia is Russia. And Russia's abiding passion has been to seize Constantinople, to seize control of the Bosteros, to seize control of the Dardanelles, so that they will then be able to get into the Mediterranean. And essentially, Turkish policy throughout the 19th century, has always been to ally with whichever powers will take their side against Russia. And most famously, that had happened in the Crimean War
when Turkey, the Ottomans, had allied with Britain and France. And now, of course, the issue is that Britain and France are allied with Russia. So therefore, the Turks were always going to ally with Germany, don't you think? Well, interestingly, Enver does actually shop around a fair bit. So they do offer a deal to the Russians and had the Russians taken it. Who knows? It's not absolutely decided in 1914, 15. The Ottomans will jump the way they do. And in fact, there are a lot of people in Constantinople who don't want to get involved at all. Well, that's the most sensible course. I mean, as with the Italians. There's a big internal Anyway, Enver, the war minister is very keen on the Germans.
And in mid-October 1914, he agrees a secret deal with the Germans. Basically, the plan is the Germans will give them a load of gold, and the Germans will promise them their Balkan territories back if they win the war. And so basically, the way they get into the war is at the end of October, Enver sends an Ottoman fleet, led by two German cruisers that are flying Ottoman colors for various complicated reasons. They go up into the Black Sea. They bombard the Russian ports in Odessa and the Crimea.
The Russians, of course, then declare war in the Ottoman Empire. And Enver and his colleagues say, brilliant, now it's on. And a couple of weeks later, the Sultan Mehmed V, they get him to proclaim a holy war, a jihad against the Allies. And this very much, you know, this excites people in Britain. It seizes their imagination. It terrifies them. It's the context for John Buckens' great thrill.
a green mantle. Comes out in 1916, doesn't it? Yeah, which has this great fear of a jihad and a holy war and a sort of general Muslim uprising across Asia. But actually in real life, this does not happen at all. And as one historian puts it, the jihad is a, and I quote, a miserable failure. So basically it doesn't get anywhere. But, I mean, it is an important context for why the British, once they've engaged in
Gallipoli, are reluctant to retreat, is that they're nervous that any loss of face might precipitate a kind of Asian-wide jihad against the empire. Exactly. So how does the war go at first for the Ottomans? It does not go well at all. So Enver takes 100,000 men and he leads them east to face the Russians in the Caucasus. And his plan is that he will encircle and destroy the Russian Caucasus army at a place called Sadakamush, which is a border town close to the border with modern day Armenia. and the conditions at Salakamish are absolutely awful even by First World War standards. So they're 10,000 feet high. There are snowstorms.
The temperature goes down to minus 26 degrees Celsius. By mid-December 1914, thousands upon thousands of men on both sides are dying of hypothermia or frostbite or typhus. Anyway, the Russians do end up getting encircled. So on the 1st of January, the Russian Supreme Commander Grand Duke Nikolai, He sends a message to Britain and he says, you know, we're in a mess against the Ottomans. Could you please stage a diversionary attack? Could you do something against the Ottomans to relieve the pressure on us? And this is where Churchill comes back into the story.
Because Churchill has been thinking about striking East even before the Ottomans entered the war. And he has been looking particularly at some way you've already mentioned, Tom, which is the Ottoman capital, Constantinople, that basically all the great powers have been eyeing very hungrily. And Dominic, which it has consistently been British policy to stop the Russians getting hold of. Correct. I mean, that's another kind of mad dimension to this story, that Churchill's plan is essentially upending centuries of British ambition to stop the Russians getting it.
Well, it's not clear what will happen to Constantinople in Churchill's plan after the war. So it's not actually clear that the Russians will get it. But the reason that it is so coveted is that Constantinople commands the narrow strait that divides Europe from Asia, but also this is the strait that divides the Black Sea from the Mediterranean. So the reason it's so important to the Russians is that this is their warm water sea route out of the Russian Empire into the seas of the world. And this strait, this waterway, basically the waterway that goes from the Sea of Marmara outside Constantinople, south to the. the Aegean in the beginning of the Mediterranean. This straight is called the Dardanelles. Now, to give people a sense,
the Dardanelles are 38 miles long, but very narrow, no more than four miles wide at their widest point. So you can imagine almost like a canal, I guess. Now, on the right-hand side, as you look at the map, the southeastern side, the Asian side, is the coast of Anatolia, of Asia Minor, specifically the city of Chanakali.
And on the left side, as you look at the map, the northwestern, the European side, that's made up of a long, narrow peninsula, which is named after one of the towns on the peninsula, which is the town of Gallipoli. So that is the Thracian-Chirsonese, as was. So Churchill has been long obsessed with this strait. So just a few weeks into the war, he had said, why don't we send a British and French fleet north through the straits? and then if necessary, if we came to war with the Ottomans, war with Turkey, we could bombard and occupy Constantinople itself. And his argument for doing this is, if it works, and that's a big if, this could be a game changer in the war.
Why? Number one, if we held Constantinople on the Straits, we'd have a warm water sea route so that we, Britain and France, could supply Russia. We could send, you know, we could send shells, we'd send whatever they needed to fight the war on the Eastern Front. Number two, if we took the straits and we were bombarding or indeed occupying Constantinople, maybe there would be a coup within the young Turk regime,
or maybe we could simply impose our own friendly regime that would change sides and bring the Ottoman Empire in on the Allied side. And if we took Constantinople, a show of force like that would surely persuade the other Balkan neutral countries. So Greece, Romania, maybe Bulgaria, maybe Italy. It would persuade them to join the war on our side. So basically everybody would pile in and we'd win the war. And in fact, even after the Gallipoli operation had failed, there were people who said, yeah, Churchill's idea wasn't that mad. So for example, we mentioned Clement Attlee. Atley had a terrible time at Gallipoli, but he always said, do you know what, on paper it was a brilliant idea and it could have worked.
Essentially, Churchill's plan requires sea power alone to win the war. So it's a bit like the reliance today on air power to win wars. That would be the kind of contemporary analogy. Yeah, I guess so. So Churchill at this point is not talking about using troops, and we'll get on to how the plan changes. But the plan is the ship sail up, they more off Concentred April, they bombard it and the Turks surrender. And then the Turks change sides. Yeah, that's magically the Turks then change sides.
It seems improbable. Well, when you look at the plan, it's very, very risky. So first of all, just sailing up the straits. There are Ottoman forts on both sides. There are mortars. There are artillery. There are underwater mines. So it's going to be very difficult just to get your ships through the straits up from the Aegean
and get them outside Constantinople. So actually, British sort of contingency plans had been talking about doing this for years. And they had always said, you know, it's much too risky. It wouldn't work. And in fact, in 1911, Churchill himself had said, It is no longer possible to force the Dardanelles, and nobody should expose a modern fleet to such peril. So he himself had seen how difficult it would be.
But now, as we've already mentioned, he looks at the Western Front, he looks at the stalemate in France and Flanders, and he says, well, anything would be better than this. He says to ask with the Prime Minister, anything would be better than sending out armies to chew barbed wire in Flanders. I mean, you can see.
the force of that argument, can't you? Of course. However, you can also see the counter-arguments. You can, yes. So anyway, Churchill gets this request from Grand Duke, Nicolai. He says, brilliant. Well, this is the opportunity we need. He sends a telegram to the commander of the Eastern Mediterranean Fleet, who's a guy called Vice Admiral Sackville Cardon. Would this work? Could we send some old ships, send them up the straits, you know, could this be done? And Churchill adds the line, importance of results would judge. justify severe loss. In other words, we could lose loads of ships and loads of men. I don't care because the prize is worth it. And so Admiral Cardin says, well, I suppose it is doable.
You know, first of all, we'd destroy the what I call the outer forts of the southern entrance to the straits. Then in phase two, we'd go in, send some ships in. We would destroy the inner forts. We'd send minesweepers in to clear the straits of mines. And then we would send our fleet in towards Constantinople. Entirely through naval operations. Yes. They're not proposing that they destroy these fleets by landing soldiers to do it. They do it with the guns from their battleships.
At this stage, there is absolutely no suggestion of using ground troops at all. They are just going to do this with naval power. That is all that they're interested in doing. And so on the 13th of January, 1915, Churchill goes to Britain's War Council, as it is called. Now, all the big names are there. Lots of people we talked about in this and other Restis History series. Herbert Henry Asquith, the Prime Minister, David Lloyd George, his Chancellor, Sir Edward Gray, the Foreign Secretary, Lord Kitchener, the Secretary of State for War, Sir John French, the British commander on the Western Front.
Oh, well, I mean, if he's there, what could possibly go wrong? Well, Asquith tells his girlfriend, Vinisha Stanley, who is a fraction of his age, you won't often see a stranger collection of men around one table. Anyway, they sit there, they talk about the Western Front and the stalemate, and then Churchill unveils his plan. And as the civil servant Morris Hankey, who was there, wrote afterwards, The idea caught on at once, the whole atmosphere changed. We turned eagerly from the dreary vista of a slogging match on the Western Front
to brighter prospects as they seemed in the Mediterranean. And Churchill says, listen, this is going to take a few weeks, Max. The Turkish guns and forts merely an inconvenience. Now actually Churchill is not being honest with them. His own admiralty experts have already told him, some of them have said specifically it's not possible, it's an impossible task. But Churchill doesn't pass this on to his colleagues because he is now completely infatuated with the scheme. And so the war council approves a plan for a naval expedition in February, we will bombard and a quote, and a quote, bombard and take the Gallipoli Peninsula with Constantinople as its objective.
Now, at this point, just to reiterate, he's not talking about doing this with any soldiers. He's talking about doing it with naval power alone. And as even his hagiographer, Andrew Roberts, says, this is mad because ships cannot hold territory. And ships cannot occupy cities. So if they get there and they bombard Constantinople and then the Turks just don't do anything, what are they going to do? You know, this is the issue. Anyway, the question is why on earth the war council has approved a plan that, I mean, Tom, if you and I can see that there are issues, why can they not see it? Now, one reason, we've already mentioned Asquith.
Asquith is distracted. There is no question, you know, Asquith has no greater defender in the world of podcasting than me. However, even I would have to concede he is not on form at this point in time. to remind people Asquith is 62 years old and he is absolutely besotted with his daughter's mate Venetia Stanley who is 27. Early that morning before the meeting in the small hours of the morning
Asgweth had written her one of his huge long love letters I give you my most intimate confidence my unceasing devotion my fears and hopes my strength and weakness my past my present my future she has now written back to him her letters are lost so we don't know what she wrote Snap out of it. Focus.
I don't think she did. Because during the meeting, while Churchill has been talking, Asquith has been reading her letter. And unbelievably, he's been writing back to her during the meeting as well. And he says to her, we are having a most interesting discussion, but so confidential and secret, I won't put anything down on paper. I'm keen to tell you all about it and to see if it meets with your approval. So it's great that Vanessa Stanley will be invited to. What are her views on?
forcing the Dardanelles. We don't know because her letters are lost. Who knows? It's a lost a military strategy. More seriously, I think a lot of the people around the table just do not take this seriously enough. They think it's this little naval gimmick and the sideshow. And if it doesn't work, we can just pull the plug and we won't have lost very much.
And lots of historians who've written about this say this was incredibly irresponsible of them. So the historian Peter Hart, read a great book about Gallipoli. A serious operation of war should not be undertaken in such a casual fashion. Hundreds of men's lives cast away on a whim as if in a mere game of sport that could be abandoned at half time. Do they have soldiers in reserve at all? Or is it entirely naval at this point? At this point it's entirely naval.
And one reason for that is, of course, if you do have soldiers hanging around, where do you want to send them? There is an urgent, desperate need for soldiers on the Western Front. Right. Remember, the pre-war army is effectively. been destroyed, the British expeditionary force. Kitchner is now raising a so-called new army, a volunteer army, to replace them. The idea that you will send 150,000, 200,000 soldiers across Europe to some mad scheme, I mean, that would appall Kichner and Sir John French and so on. Because there's no way that even, say, the very best happens when they capture Constantinople,
it's not going to help the war on the Western Front, is it? No, no. And that's where the war is going to be won or lost. This is exactly the point, that this is. a massive, massive distraction. And what is more, the great rationale for this, which is we're going to help out the Russians, has now disappeared. Because even as they are having these meetings, in mid-January, it becomes clear that actually
this encircumment at Salakamash has actually worked out in the Russians' favour, not the Ottomans. Enver has made a terrible mess of things. If it's 100,000 men, about 80,000 of them are killed, they die of frostbite or freezing to death or typhus or whatever. The Russians then basically pile in to Western Armenia, eastern Turkey. And this is the point at which Enver and the Young Turk leadership say,
well, it's not our fault that we lost this terrible battle. It's actually the fault of fifth columnists and traitors within the Armenians. Who stabbed us in the back. Who stabbed us in the back. And this is what sets the stage for the Armenian genocide, which begins just a few weeks later. Now, meanwhile, in London, Churchill, of course, is oblivious to all this. he doesn't care about any of this.
He is just thrilled that his pet scheme has got the go-ahead. And when he goes back to the Admiralty and says, it's on, we have to do this. A lot of his colleagues are horrified. Most obviously, the first sea lord. So this is the senior, you know, naval officer, effectively at the Admiralty. He is Admiral Lord Fisher, Jackie Fisher. A great celebrity in 1910s, Britain.
Well, he'd launched the Dreadnought, hadn't it? The first Dreadnought, HMS Dreadnought. the kind of the prototype for that entire class. He had been the man in charge of the Navy before the war and he'd been brought back from retirement in 1914. Jan Morris's great hero. She loved him. He was writing books about him.
He is a remarkable, remarkable character. So he's very short, very stocky. He's bright yellow because he had malaria when he was young. He's extremely religious. When he was ashore, he would try to go to church two or three times a day, which seems a lot to me. oddly for somebody who's such a great naval hero he suffered from seasickness on the other hand he was an incredibly good and enthusiastic dancer how did he have time with all the
church and the i also want dancing on board ship if you see sick sloshing all over the exactly anyway fisher is a great character everybody loves fisher they're very excited that he's been brought brack rather like bringing back kitchener to run the war office but actually as as with kitchener jucky fisher is a bit of a loose cannon he's 73 years old he's very autocratic. He's very indecisive. He's very difficult. He spends most of his time leaking to the Tory press and saying, I hate Churchill. Churchill's useless. And he really hates the Dardanelles scheme. Fisher says, this is absolutely insane. The only way this could work is if you landed 200,000, it would take 200,000 men to secure the coastline so you could get your ships through the strait.
And frankly, we don't have enough men to send 200,000 men. Churchill doesn't listen to him. Fisher is more and more enraged. He goes to see Lloyd George's secretary-stroke mistress of Francis Stevenson, and he says, people at the Admiralty are trying to argue with Churchill, and I quote, but he simply overrides them and talks them down. If he continues his domineering course, they fear there may be a catastrophe. But Fisher's not good at the internal politics, and Churchill is. So when they have meetings, Churchill's very excited and abilient and tells everybody about
scheme. Fisher sits there, sulking, staring out of the window, you know, irritable, difficult, so people don't listen to him. They listen to Churchill instead. So anyway, they sign off on the scheme. On 19th of February, Admiral Cardin's fleet, combined British and French fleet, launches the first stage of the operation. So the French of sight they've joined as well? The French are involved as well, exactly, in much smaller numbers. Nobody ever talks about the French at Gallipoli, but there are French ships and will in due course be French troops. And they've basically joined because they are, they're the allies, they've got ships. Yeah, exactly.
So they're in the Mediterranean too. So they start by shelling these outer forts at the entrance to the straits. And they're horrified when they get there to find out that the Ottomans whom they've assumed will be completely useless, have spent the winter laying minefields, preparing kind of howitzers, bringing up, you know, reinforcing their artillery batteries and whatnot. So basically, this is going to be tougher than they thought. Takes them a week, they finally knock out these outer forts, they clear some of the minefields. Churchill is thrilled with all this. He's sitting next to Asquith's daughter, Violet, at a dinner.
He says, I love this war. I know it is smashing and shattering the lives of thousands every moment, and yet I can't help it. I enjoy every second of it. So people may reflect on those words when we get into the suffering of some of the troops, Gallipoli. And he says, this operation of mine is going brilliantly.
Soon the Royal Naval Division will be marching into Constantinople. That will make them sit up, the swine who snarled at the naval division. He's talking about the people
who said they were useless at Antwerp. And in fact, Churchill is so giddy now that three days after this so the 25th of February, so that's six days after the operation began. He goes to the War Council and he says,
we will be in Constantinople by the end of March. We will be able to capture and destroy all Turkish forces in Europe, and we will eliminate Turkey as a military factor in the war. Some chicken, some neck. I mean, absolutely insane from Churchill. The next phase is scheduled for mid-March, and this is the full-scale attack on the inner
forts inside the Straits. Now, at this point, one of the big flaws in Churchill's scheme has become apparent, and this is he has forgotten that there's another side in this. which is the Ottomans. And the Ottomans will see what's going on, and they will reinforce accordingly. And that is, of course, exactly what the Ottomans have done. They've made more minds.
They've brought up more artillery. And some of Churchill's own, you know, subordinates, are now becoming extremely anxious about this. So Admiral Cardin, who was already ill, two days before the operation, has a complete nervous breakdown and has to be sort of taken away. And he is replaced by his vice-admiral,
John de Robeck, who has always thought the whole scheme was mad. However, the whole thing goes ahead anyway. The big day is Thursday the 18th of March. It's a lovely day. Beautiful, sunny sort of spectacle. 16 British and French ships steam towards the entrance to the narrows, the straits. And immediately things go wrong.
So one of the French ships, the bouvet, hits a mine and explodes. And it sinks so quickly that of more than 700 men aboard this ship, all but 75. of them are drowned. And then two more ships, British ships, HMS Irresistible and HMS Inflexible, they hit Turkish mines too. Inflexible manages to get away, but irresistible is totally crippled. And then they send another ship to try to rescue them, HMS Ocean, and that is hit first
by a Turkish shell, then by a Turkish mine, and that sinks two. So by nightfall, when Robex says, okay, we're calling off this off, this has been an absolute shambles. They have cleared one line of mines out of nine. Of 176 Turkish shoreguns, they have knocked out precisely four. And of their 16 ships, three of them have been sunk and three of them have been badly damaged. So this has been a terrible day. I mean, it's gone really badly. The next day, Churchill goes to the war council. He reads out the telegrams reporting what's gone on. And he says, it's actually going fine. Yeah, we've taken a few losses. He doesn't mention the French ship and its men at all. He says, we've lost less than 30 British lives
and two or three worthless ships. So the French, he just forgets about them. It doesn't count them. And then he says, well, now that it's going to say, well, is this perhaps the moment to discuss partitioning the Ottoman Empire? And Admiral Fisher says, you are mad. Quote, we told you to use troops as well, but you wouldn't listen. And Churchill himself wrote after the war, For the first time since the war began, high words were used around the octagonal table. In other words, people are now saying to him, you have totally led us. Yeah. You've led us into an absolute mess. This is a shambles. Lots of people have died. What are you talking about partitioning Turkey? We're nowhere remotely near to conquering Turkey. You're mad. And this is the moment when
they should clearly have said, stop. Enough. Pull the plug. And they don't. And the reason they don't, it's partly because there's Churchill there who's a force of nature, who's basically clearly going to have a massive tantrum if they don't continue with this scheme. It's partly because they've already lost lives and ships. So it's that classic thing of, you know, pouring good money after bad. You know, you have to justify the initial investment, the initial sacrifice. And the only way to do that is to keep, you know, throwing resources down the sink, as it were. But also, Lord Kitchener raises the point about the jihad that you mentioned earlier.
He says, we cannot afford to lose to an Asian Muslim power because the authority of our empire is based on the perception of our superiority. Quote, the effect of a defeat in the Orient would be very serious. I mean, there's a slight kind of Trump wanting to pull out of the Iran war. A really good analogy is Vietnam. You know, a humiliation or a defeat here would be so catastrophic for America's image abroad that we just have to keep pouring and pouring men
and hoping that something will change. And so the War Council makes the fateful decision that they will double down. They will send in the fleet for another go, but first they will prepare the ground. They decide we will send a small expeditionary force to the European side of. of the Straits. We will land troops on the Gallipoli Peninsula, and it should be a very easy job
to take the peninsula and to knock out all the Ottoman forts and batteries along that side of the coastline, and then we can send our ships through. It will be dead easy, and nothing could possibly go wrong. But could it? We will find out after a break. This episode is brought to you by Disclosure Day. The new movie Disclosure Day is directed by legendary filmmaker Stephen Spielberg. And now with Disclosure Day, Spielberg is back with another movie which asks the fascinating question, what would you do if you found out that we here on planet Earth were not alone? See, I feel quite good about it because I've actually been prepping for some years.
So I've laid up stores. I've got weaponry. I'm ready. When the aliens attack, I will be able to fight back with the arsenal of my disposal. So I'm excited about it. But Dominic, you are not actually appearing in this cast because the cast is a really extraordinary one. And clearly Spielberg didn't need you because he's got Emily Blunt. He has got Colin Firth. He's got Josh O'Connor. He's got Coleman Domingo. And it's a completely gripping and original story.
And absolutely it demands to be seen not on TV, but on the big screen. Disclosure Day is in cinemas. June 10th. So book your tickets now. It's nearly that time, everyone. The rest is football will be on Netflix every day for the world's biggest tournament. Join myself, Alan and Micah for daily debates, unfiltered takes and the most special of guests. All from the heart of New York City. Yeah, that's right. We're excited too. See you soon. From the pitch to the stands to communities around the world. The beautiful game is coming to our beautiful country,
uniting fans around a shared passion. Now you have the opportunity to hold this chapter of Canadian soccer history in the palm of your hands. Score the FIFA World Cup 2026, $1 coin today. Look forward in your change. Hello everyone and welcome back to the rest of history. Dominant, you said before the break that this scheme, that Churchill has cooked up for sending land forces onto Gallipoli that nothing could go wrong.
Is his confidence justified? Well, we will discover. Churchill says to them, and I quote, there should be no difficulty in affecting and landing. It doesn't occur to him that it will be at all tricky to land thousands of troops on enemy territory, a long way from home, what will effectively be an amphibious landing, facing modern weaponry. This is something that has never been done before. So can I just ask, the nearest land bases that Britain has are what, Egypt and Cyprus? Egypt, yeah. So they have troops in Egypt. And as we will see, those are the Anzaks. Who are they going to bring over?
So the man who has chosen to command the operation is one of Churchill's closest friends in the army. He's a guy called Sir Ian Hamilton. So Ian Hamilton is often given a very bad press in books about Gallipoli. You know, you mentioned lions led by donkeys. I mean, he's definitely not a donkey. If you were being very critical of him, you'd say he was a bit of a dilettante. And in fact, that's the criticism that people make. He fought in both Burr Wars, decorated. He's a novelist. He's a poet.
He is regarded as, you know, the most cerebral, the most intellectual of the British Army's senior officers. He's got a kind of quite a wry, sardonic sense of humour. I like his line after the war. He said, there is nothing certain about war. except that one side won't win. And I think that's, you know, that suggests that he's not, he's not absurdly over-optimistic. Hamilton, however, has been dealt a very rough hand. He is being asked, as a reminder, he is being asked to carry out the first ever landing,
you know, by sea on enemy territory facing modern technology. He's been given a month to planet. So this is not D-Day, you know, months and months in the planet. planning. This is going to be much quicker. But presumably even a month is giving the Ottomans time to beef up their defences. Of course. The Ottomans know what's coming. I mean, they're not idiots. And also, another contrast with Sadi-Day. And his task has made harder because the Secretary of Lord Lord Kitchinner gives him a very rag-tag collection of troops, many of them untested and untrained.
So to give people a sense, there's the 29th division of the British Army, and that had basically been cobbled together by loads of colonial garrisons. So people who've been serving all over, you know, Asia or whatever are now told you're going to come back and you're going to fight and you're going to be lumped in with these other blokes. Then there is Churchill's Royal Naval Division. Churchill's so proud of this, you know, his favourite child or whatever. They're basically a load of naval reservists and volunteers who signed up to join the Navy when the war broke out, but there was nothing for them to do. So they've been told, you know, you're going to be like a sort of little naval marine force fighting on land.
Right. Then there's the French, the Orient Expeditionary Corps, as they are called. And a lot of these people are colonial troops from Algeria and from Senegal. So they're there too. And then most famously, the Anzaks, the Australian Imperial Force and the New Zealanders Expeditionary Force. And these had been made up of volunteers sent by the two dominions of Australia and New Zealand to the outbreak of war, they thought they were going to fight in Europe, and they have been
training in the desert outside Cairo. So that will prepare them for the mud of Flanders. Right. So after the war, Australian writers in particular absolutely lionised these guys. And they said these were the embodiments of the Anzac spirit. They are free-spirited, manly sons of the outback and of the outdoors. What a contrast between our brave boys and the sort of sickly pallid products of Britain's industrial cities. It's like a kind of Australian ashes preview.
Exactly, exactly. Now, actually, this is slightly misleading. A quarter of the Australian Imperial Force had actually been born in Britain. So these are people who were British but have emigrated to Australia and now have decided that they will sign up. And actually, a lot of the others were not sons of the outback at all. they came from cities themselves, cities like Sydney and Melbourne. And as Australian historians have actually done lots of work in showing, they're not always the most admirable adverts for Australian virtues.
You know, Tom, I like Australia a lot. We've been there on tour. I'm a big fan of Australia and Australians and indeed of New Zealanders. But actually in Cairo, these blokes don't bring great credit on the... Cairo. Yeah, it's Cairo. They don't bring credit on the Australian flag. There's a lot of fighting.
There's a lot of drunkenness. There's a lot of looting. There's a lot of sexual misbehavior. There's allegations of rape. Two out of ten of these blokes at some point get venereal disease. And in fact, there is a thing that's apparently very well known in Australia called the Battle of the Wazer. What's that? This is when they run a mock on Good Friday, because they've all got VD from the lady.
of the night, Egyptian ladies of the night. And they run amok through the brothels of Cairo trying to locate the women who they think have given them the clap, basically. Oh. And there's a huge, there's a massive riot, basically, as they run a mock. Anyway. But I suppose it helps to build up elite mateship. Do you think so?
Elite mateship is what the Anzac spirit is all about. It's all about mateship. Yeah. So they could not be in a better condition. They're ready to have a crack, a crack at the Turk. Take on the Turk. Exactly. Anyway, so basically this is Hamilton's force.
They haven't trained together. A lot of them are barely trained at all. They don't have enough guns. Their officers have no experience with this kind of operation. Basically, because nobody has any experience with this kind of operation. It hasn't really been done before. I mean, the more you go on, the matter the whole scheme seems. But the rationale for it to obviously is they say, yeah, but all that doesn't matter
because it's only the Turks. So as soon as we get ashore, the Turks will undoubtedly run away. Because they are just hanging around smoking hookahs and drinking very thick coffee. Well, this brings us to Johnny Turk, as the Tommy's and the Anzaks called him. So there's obviously a massive sense of racial superiority that underlies all this. I mean, the Turks, the Ottomans, are not a joke at all. They are battle-hardened. They have just fought two Balkan wars and they fought the Italians in Libya.
This time, they will be fighting very clearly in defense of their nation. land for their native soil. The idea that they're just going to run away is laughable. And they have been very busy. So this German guy, Otto Lehman von Sanders, he has been modernizing the Ottoman army and he has now been moved specifically to the Dardanelles and told, take charge of the Fifth Army, the Ottoman Fifth Army is going to defend the straits from these blokes. And Lehman has been given 200,000 men. And he thinks, well, you know, he's not an idiot. He can see what's happened on the Western Front and whatnot.
And he says, right, well, obviously what we're going to do is we're just going to wait for them to land and then we'll just kill them all. We'll let them approach us. We'll establish trenches. We'll establish our barbed wire. We will lay mines. We will have supply roads ready to bring up more ammunition. We will prepare our positions on the high ground. When the Allies land, you know, we will basically just drive them into the sea or side them down with our machine guns.
So we now get to mid-April. On the 10th of April, Sarian Hamilton and his senior officers arrive on the island of Lemnos in the northern Aegean. And two days later, they are joined there by the Anzaks from Egypt, and then by the 29th division of the British Army, and also by the French. Meanwhile, Churchill's Royal Naval Division have been training on the island of Skiros, which is to the south of Lemnos. and one of the men on the island is the Cambridge-educated poet Rupert Brooke and Rupert Brooke is 27 years old he is described by W.B. Yates as the handsomest man in England
I always find that kind of ludicrous like has Yates seen every other man in England? No, he hasn't. I mean he is in an absolute lather of excitement about all the classical and the historical associations, isn't he? Yeah. I mean, Troy is just, up the Dardanelles and he dreams of fighting there on the plane of Troy. And he comes up with this amazing phrase, which I think speaks for so many of us. He wrote, I suddenly realized that
the ambition of my life has been since I was two to go on a military expedition against Constantinople. I mean, his dream will come true, or will it? Well, will it? Brook has already imagined his own death, of course, very famously, some of the most famous lines written in the First World War. If I should die, think only this of me, that there is some corner of a foreign field that is forever England. Yeah, and he wants to die if he has to die like Achilles, bravely, in the heat of battle on the plane of Troy. Yeah. He will lead his men over the plain of Troy and a beating sunshine. In a chariot. You know, everyone cheering. Yeah. The most handsome man in England in burning armour. How does he die, Dominic? He's bitten on the lip by a mosquito.
The mosquito bite becomes infected, and he dies of blood poisoning on the 23rd of April. So he hasn't even seen an Ottoman defender. He hasn't set foot on the soil of Asia. He hasn't even got to the Gallipoli Peninsula. He's dead before he's set off. And this report in the newspapers, the Asquith family, knew him very well. They were devastated, but this. Churchill knew him, was devastated, wrote a absolute,
sort of tear-stained, syrupy, obituary for him, I think, in the times. And you might say this is quite a bad omen that this bloke who was going to lead the kind of attack on Troy. I just think generally attacking Troy is not sensible. Yeah. It's going to go on for 10 years at least. There's a slight sign at this point. I think that Churchill is beginning to wobble himself.
Lloyd George said he was looking worried and looking ill. The former Tory Prime Minister Arthur Balfour asked Churchill. Is it, how's it going to go this business at Gallipoli? You know, you must be absolutely, bet you can't wait. And Churchill's then said, I think there's nothing for it, but to go through with the business. No one can count with certainty on the issue of a battle, which suggests that he is beginning to wobble. And then he says, but we have the chances in our favour and we play for vital gains with non-vital stakes. And I think the tens and tens of thousands of men who died at Gallipi would be probably quite offended to be referred to.
be referred to as non-vital stakes. Anyway, the landings were initially set for the 23rd of April, the day that Brooke died. But they are postponed by two days because of bad weather. Another bad omen, possibly, we shall see. The plan calls for two distractions to kind of confuse the Turks. So the French will land at Kumkala in Asia. They'll get off their ships, then they'll get back on again and come back the other side. This is to trick the Turks.
What a wheeze. And then a brilliant wheeze, actually. The Royal Naval Division will pretend to land at a place called Bolleia, which is in the north of the peninsula. And actually, they get New Zealand's greatest war hero, Bernard Freyberg. He swims ashore and lights flares on the beach to distract the defenders. And then he swims back again. And this is an incredible feat of New Zealand plot.
There's not as much New Zealand action in this story as there should be. Well, New Zealanders are generally more retiring, aren't they, I think, than Australians. Unless it comes to rugby. Yeah, I guess. They're putting all their energy into rugby and not enough into boasting about their martial feats. Is that true? Yeah, all swimming ashore and lighting flares. Exactly, which I think is very impressive.
So these are the distractions, and then there'll be two landings. Landing number one is the two ANZAC divisions led by the third Australian Infantry Brigade. They all land on the western side of the Gallipoli. peninsula at this sort of crescent bay, sandy bay, which ends up being called Anzac Cove. And meanwhile, the British, the 29th Division, will land at the very southern tip of the peninsula, which is called Cape Helles, and there are five beaches, SV, W, X and Y around this tip, and they will land at these five beaches. Can I just ask, are they more British than Anzac's?
Yes. Because that's not the sense you get, is it, generally? Are you dissing Australian stuff? No, I'm not dissing. I mean, my sense is that Gallipoli was entirely fought by Anzax. I think that's the kind of the vague sense you have. Yeah. And that there are British generals lurking in the background being sinister and posh and like Douglas Jardine.
Yeah, drinking tea. Yeah. They're drinking tea and swimming, the British on the beach, while Australian plucky Australian boys who've come with court hats from the outback are being mown down by cruel Turkish gunners. Loads of British are being mown down as well. Well, we will see. Yeah, loads of British swimming mode down. Yeah.
So the plan is you will land, you'll establish your beachhead, and then you will push inland. The terrain is not ideal. It's these kind of scrublands, these hills, these deep ravines. But the planners say, don't worry, the Turks will crumble as soon as our lads get ashore. Well, will they? We'll find out. We'll start with the Anzac, 16,000 of them. Remember, these are untrained soldiers, untested, and they're attempting something very difficult.
to landing at sea at night against machine guns and barbed wire. I mean, has this ever happened before? No. No one has ever done this before. I mean, that's a massive ask. It's huge. But you've come all the way from Australia. You've had, what, six months of training?
You've got to do something that no one in military history has done. It's insane. And this is why D-Day, and this is arguably why D-Day is so remarkable. Well, it's partly because they had the lesson of Gallipoli. I mean, Goli is in the back of their minds all through D-Day. because it was such a shambles. So to go back to the Anzaks, they've been given a very narrow window of time
between 3 o'clock in the morning and 4 o'clock in the morning. So this is the time between, you know, the moon will vanish at 3, the sun will come up at 4, this is your time. The assumption is it will be very straightforward and it doesn't turn out that way.
So this is Private Waltos Stagles of the 3rd Australian Battalion. He was part of the second wave that went ashore. I'll read what he said. It was pitch dark, then all of a sudden the coast A dim outline of the coast loomed up. As we got closer, we were all beginning to get tensed up, nervous, wondering what was going to happen, as everything was so quiet.
Then a single shot rang out and a yellowish light flared up in the sky, and from then on the Turks let loose, machine gun and rifle fire at the boats. As soon as the boats grounded, it was every man for himself. And it's very saving private Ryan. So an army surgeon, Australian surgeon, wrote in his diary that he watched the men going ashore and draw this Turkish fire. Several fell as they ran and on the beach I saw even more men lying untidily. Some quite still, others making an occasional movement. Then I jumped over in a two feet of water and waded heavily ashore.
The lapping edge was already pink and frothy with fallen men. Oh, God. So it takes them about four hours to get their men ashore the Anzax. That's amazing. They do get ashore, really. It is. It's very impressive. I mean, that opening reading, I mean, they do perform very, very bravely.
Yeah. They start to push up the hill up inland, but it is clear that their guiding assumption was wrong. The Turks have not cut and run, quite the reverse. So this is another guy, Eric Moorhead from Victoria. He says basically they went up the hill, they're expecting to see the enemy there. We were now in a scrub-covered plane fairly in the open. No Turks would have be seen, but the air was literally full of bullets and the sound was deafening. The point-blank explosion of rifles and the concealed snipers firing on us at close quarters.
Our bayonet charge had failed, the men became disorganised. Some runabout distractedly poking in the bushes for Turks. Others fell on their faces, nerve-wracked by the terrible fire. So what has happened is this. The Ottoman troops have let them come inland. And then at the point where the Turks might have panicked under the Australian onslaught, they have rallied, and this is thanks to somebody who already mentioned in this episode, their frontline commander, lieutenant colonel, Mustafa Kemmel.
So up to this point, as we said, he's an obscure sort of nationalist army officer. Born in Salonica, he's a big drinker, he's very intense, very driven. But people haven't heard of him. And this is the moment where particularly within the army, he becomes a national hero. Because at 10 o'clock that morning, Mustafa Kemal is heading towards the front line. And he sees some of the Turkish troops retreating. And he says, why are you running away? Sir, the enemy, where, over there?
and they point to this place that the Australians end up calling Battleship Hill about two miles inland, which is where the Australians have got to. And Mustafa Akemil comes out with this line that becomes part of Turkish nationalist mythology. He says to his troops, I don't order you to attack. I order you to die. By the time we're dead, other troops and other commanders will be ready to take our places. And amazingly, I mean, I would find that terrifying. probably would continue running away.
But the Turks are made of sterner stuff than I am. And they turn round and they run back into their fray. And they drive the Australians back down towards the beach. I mean, the Australians do love a beach. Australians do love a beach. But you wouldn't associate Australians for going backwards, would you? No, you wouldn't. But that is precisely what they are doing by mid-afternoon.
Far from going forwards and pushing inland, they're being driven back towards the sea. Their officers are being sithed down by Turkish machine guns. and they're absolutely shattered. Of course, I mean, imagine how exhausted they must be after making this landing. So this is Private Herbert Filders of the 12th Battalion. Four of us lay under shrapnel machine gun and rifle fire,
not daring to lift our heads the whole while. If we'd budged or would have been killed dozens of times over. The bullets were streaming so thick over our heads. Our officers said he'd never seen anything like it, and he's an old soldier. I was jolly tired, too. As a matter of fact, I went to sleep twice. That's impressive. That's so impressive.
I mean, do you think, is this worse than fighting it on the Western Front? It is really, isn't it? Yeah, I think in the grand scheme of things. I mean, you're kind of in the open, aren't you? You don't know what you're doing? You're blundering around all these, your mad landscape. Yeah, it's really hot. As we will see, particularly in our next episode, in Thursday's episode.
I think the conditions are Gallipoli are just unbelievably hellish. Yeah. And they're definitely worse than the Western Front. And a lot of people who served on both said, you know, the Western Front wasn't brilliant. But the one thing it had in its favour was it wasn't Gallipoli, which was so much worse. Yeah, it sounds awful. So anyway, this bloke who fell asleep. He was hit three times in the legs, but he still managed to get that to the beach, which is very impressive.
Have a bobby. Anyway, night falls, the Anzaks do have a foothold. They've got this little pocket with a kind of perimeter, which is about two miles long. But in total, they've basically got only half a mile. in land. They are nowhere near where they were meant to be, and they've already lost 2,000 men out of their 16,000 killed, wounded or missing. So that's the Anzax. Now, meanwhile, the British have been landing further south at Cape Helles. And this is actually the bigger landing. This is 21,000 men of the 29th Division. And they're given a tremendous send-off by their
commanding officer, Major General Ayelma Hunter Western. Hunter Bunta. He says to them, The eyes of the world are upon us. Your deeds will live in history. To us now is given the opportunity of avenging our friends and relatives who have died in France and Flanders. So I looked him up. Yeah. Moustache. Very good moustache.
Excellent moustache. I think the best British military moustache I've seen so far. I think the moustaches at Gallipoli, by and large, are better than across the board than British moustaches on the Western Front. So Ataturk had an excellent moustache. It's a pencil, though. Hunter Buntus moustache. is so ect British military officer in the First World War. It's the platonic archetype of it.
Do look at it. Do have a look. Anyone who's a fan of military moustaches. Right. Now, things here at Cape Helles do not go according to plan at all. So I mentioned there are five beaches and the main ones. We'll forget three of them. We'll just talk about two of them, W and V. So the first wave to land at W Beach are the first Lancashire Fusiliers.
and when they get there they find that the Turks are waiting with all their barbed wire and their machine guns. I mean, this is Captain Harold Clayton. There was tremendously strong barbed wire when my boat landed. Men were being hit on the boats and as they splashed ashore. I got up to my waist and water. I tripped over a rock and went under. I got up and made for the shore and laid down by the barbed wire. The front of the wire by now is a thick mass of men,
the majority of whom never moved again. The trenches on the right raped us and those above us raked our right, while trenches and machine guns fired straight down the valley. The noise was ghastly. The sight's horrible. I mean, just, so they've got inland. They're stuck on the barbed wire and they're just being absolutely raked with machine gun fire.
So the Lancash Fusiliers, they went to shore with 27 officers and 1,002 men. They end the day with 16 officers and just 304 men. But have they secured a foothold? They have secured a little foothold. I mean, they definitely got ashore. So that's something. Now, if you think that's bad, V Beach is the real shocker. So V Beach, the Turks had really put a lot of effort into reinforcing this beach.
They had put two lines of barbed wire and then behind them to various lines of trenches. So one of the British naval commanders, who's called Edward Unwin, comes up with a clever plan that you and indeed Rupert Brooke would admire. He says, look, we're just across the straits from Troy. And, you know, if you've done classics at public school, as I have, then you will know how to cope with Trojans. We need a Trojan horse. Not a literal horse. Not a literal horse, but a ship.
Roll the enormous horse on the beach. I mean, it would be original. Frankly. I mean, it couldn't go worse. I wouldn't put it past them. And you're not wrong. It couldn't go worse than what they actually did. So they said, instead of using a,
a horse, a wooden horse, we'll use a bloody big ship like a huge old collier, a coal ship called the SS River Clyde. We will put 2,000 men, we'll put loads of ammo, and we'll put loads of supplies in this big old ship, and then we will deliberately run it aground.
We'll run the ship aground as close to the beach as possible. We'll have another little ship coming up called a steamhopper, and this will go in between the ship and the actual sand. So all the men will be able to jump off the River Clyde onto the steamhopper and then jump off the steamhopper onto the sands and run up the beach. Brilliant. And then this big ship that's stuck on the beach, the River Clyde, we can use that as our headquarters, as a little field hospital,
as a kind of supply depot, all of this. I think it's quite a good idea. Do you? How does it go? Well, we'll find out. So they start bombarding the beach. and then they're going to send up the Dublin fusiliers first and little rowing boats and then this bloody big ship, the River Clyde.
The Dublin fuseliers make very slow progress, so unfortunately they land out of order. The River Clyde lands first or crashes a ground, but it hasn't got as close to the beach as they hoped it would. It's still 80 yards away. So the men can't jump out and wade. They will just drown. So this is where your steam hopper little boat, which would act as a bridge.
kind of a gangway comes in. Unfortunately, the steam hopper has also run aground, but on the wrong side of the ship and pointing the wrong way. So they can't use that at all. So they're all stuck on this boat offshore. Like how are we going to get off? At this point, the Dublin fusiliers and their rowing boats come into land, and they are absolutely sitting ducks for the Turkish machine gunners
who basically sigh through them. Some of the Dublin blokes jump out and they try to wade ashore, but their packs are so heavy that, they can't really make any progress. They end up being riddled with Turkish bullets. It's a terrible, terrible scene. Private Robert Martin. There were 25 in my boat and there were only three of us left.
It was terrible to hear our poor chums moaning and to see the poor boys dead in the water. Others on the beach roaring for help, but we could do nothing for them. Those who were left wounded on the shore. In the evening, the tide came in and they were all drowned. And I was left by myself on the beach. So that's not great.
No. And then what about this ship, the River Clyde? Yeah, I'm sure that comes to the rescue. It's just sitting there. It's just sitting there, right? And the Turks are just hammering shells at it and bullets. Oh, it's a mad idea to have done that then. Yeah, precisely, right?
Stupid idea. Because the men can't jump off. They're in six feet of water. Their packs are so heavy, they will just be dragged down and drowned. And this guy who came up with the idea, Unwin, can see that it's all falling apart. So his massive credit, he says, I will fix this. and he takes an able seaman with the excellent name of William Williams.
They jump into the sea. They've got all these barges with them. They lash together all the barges with ropes. And they literally hold them in place, these two guys, as a gangway. Okay, that is impressive. Right. And the Turks are firing at them and they don't hit these two blokes, which is so impressive. That these guys are such courage.
And the men start jumping down from the ship onto the gangway. but they are being raped all the time with Turkish bullets. So the first 200 men, only 21 of them reached the beach alive. And there was a petty officer who was watching from the ship, and he wrote in his diary, he said, one after another, the devoted fellows made the dash down the deadly gangways. But to our horror we saw them suddenly begin to flounder and fall in the water. They went down, never to reappear, as the hailing bullets flicked the life out of the struggling men. We almost wept with impotent rage.
So they're leaping off, they're incredibly bravely kind of running across this kind of improvised gangway, and they're all being shot down. After about an hour, the shallows are absolutely choked with dead and drowning men. The able seaman William Williams, he shot and killed. And Unwin, who's been holding the gangway in place, kind of from not so it won't be swept away by the tide. He basically collapses with exhaustion. He has to be dragged back aboard the ship. And at this point, the commanding officers on the river, I'd say, this has been in a complete nightmare.
Let's just wait here, stop trying to get off the ship and wait for cover of darkness and then try to get to shore. But, I mean, this is why you should never be too brave, Tom. And I don't think this is an issue that we will ever have to face, frankly, but just so you know, don't be too courageous. Because at this point, one of the infantry commanders who is called Brigadier General Napier says, no, no, we can still do this. And he jumps down from the ship onto the gangway. And he says, go on, men. and somebody shouts at him, you can't possibly land.
And Napier says, I'll have a damn good try. And he starts to run across these barges followed by his loyal major and some of his men. He gets to barge number three and a bullet just smacks into his head and he falls into the water
and his body was never recovered. And so that was the end of him. I suppose he couldn't recognise it if his head's been blown to pieces. I guess. His second in command, his major is right behind him. A second bullet hits the major
the major raises himself to one knee carry on men and then another bullet hits him and that's the end of him as well so basically they're all killed by mid-afternoon there are still only 200 men on the beach and they're huddling for cover sort of under punishing Turkish fire
and there's a thousand bloke still on the river Clyde and only when darkness falls and the Turkish firing dies down can the rest of them get ashore? And they get ashore a lot of them by basically using the bodies as a bridge. But just to be clear, if they're all now on the beach, I mean, they're just exposed...
Well, it's night. Yeah, I know, but when dawn comes, when they all just be shot to pieces? Well, no, because they do manage to push a little... At Cape Helles, they do manage to push a little way inland. So they lost 2,000 men, and they'd lost 2,000 men at Anzac Cove. But in the south, they do manage to push a little bit further.
So it's a great triumph. Well, they have not come remotely close to realizing their objectives or to getting to where they wanted to. And it is terrifyingly obvious to them at this point that the Turks are not the sort of pushovers they thought they were. That they are dug in. They are well supplied. They're extremely well motivated. And the last thing the Turks are going to do is to run away. And that evening, the Anzac commander, who was called William Bird,
He sent a signal to Saran Hamilton. And he said, you know, my men have performed heroically, but they are thoroughly demoralized by snipers, shrapment, man, and shellfire. If we have to resume fighting tomorrow, he says, there is likely to be a fiasco. You need to get us out of here right away. And Hamilton actually talks to the naval officers. Can this be done?
And the naval guys say to him, it's actually not possible. We cannot. There are no plans. You know, we don't have the, we haven't prepared. We literally cannot physically get them out at such short notice. And so Hamilton says the signal back to the Anzaks. Dig yourselves right in and stick it out. Dig, dig, dig until you are safe.
And so this is what they are doing. And is this where the word diggers for Anzac troops comes from? I think it is actually. Yeah, this is my assumption, I guess, although I'm not certain. So both at Anzac Cove and at Cape Helles further south, the men are now digging trenches. And this, of course, is the grim irony of all this, that this whole operation was meant to avoid the horrors of the Western Front.
It was a diversion from the Western Front. And now, after all, they are back in the trenches. And I assume that it is much harder to dig trenches here than it is in the mud of Flanders. Definitely is. Definitely is in the chalk lands of the Aen or something. So the question now, now that they've landed, what's the plan? Is Churchill finally going to accept that this mad scheme has failed?
Or is he going to throw in more men? We'll find out next time. Yeah, there's only one way to do that. And that is to listen to the next episode. And of course, members of the Restis History Club can do so right away. And if you're not a member of the Restis History Club, and you would like to listen to the next episode immediately and enjoy a host of supplementary benefits, then you can, of course, go to the rest ishistory.com where you will get them all.
But for now, Dominic, thank you very much for what's been a very grim story. And I suspect that in the next episode, it will get even grammar. Goodbye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.